they were warned to prepare but how do
you prepare for this
water pouring through this home and all
the owner can do is helplessly watch a
live feed on camera
hurricane ida has well and truly arrived
now bringing 240 kilometer an hour winds
and chaos to louisiana
the storm is a life-threatening storm
the big one hits the big easy 16 years
to the day since katrina arrived in new
orleans killing more than 1800 people
and causing billions of dollars worth of
damage now a storm that hit land with
even more power to give an idea that is
a picnic table between those poles the
water just pouring over the top
up in the skies this flight taking us
into the eye of the storm it is calm up
there but what a difference on the
ground hurricane ida's path is taking
her around the western side of new
orleans which means this city is being
hit by the winds from the eastern side
of the storm and that is not a place you
want to be in the midst of a category 4
hurricane because those eastern winds
tend to be stronger they tend to be more
powerful and cause much more devastation
and the risks here are huge everything
from debris flying through the air to
fences coming loose and hitting people
to downed power lines and that's before
we even get onto the subject of the
water the flooding from the rain and
those storm surges
which is what we saw with hurricane
katrina where 80 percent of this city
ended up submerged new orleans told to
evacuate in case this happened again in
central areas it was voluntary
governor edwards no friend is
characterized as one of the strongest
hurricanes
the strongest in louisiana history since
1850
and uh his devastation is likely to be
immense we shouldn't kid ourselves
in lower lying areas it was mandatory
and still some stayed
i would say half the neighborhood is
staying and the other half is evacuated
so it's it's more just to kind of be
here to help
as the storm heads north it'll be hours
before the extent of the devastation
becomes clear most are hunkering down
[Music]
but some refuse the hurricanes may cause
damage and death but in true style new
orleans refuses to give
in well we can speak to phil lavelle he
is live for us in new orleans uh some
dramatic uh footage there in your
package what is the situation where you
are now
situation right now is that we are in
complete darkness the power went off a
couple of hours ago this is the french
quarter so this is a place where they
typically don't lose power um but we
have i mean it's been like this for ios
there is a few lights in the distance
some businesses are lucky enough to have
their own generators but they are few
and far between and the entire city is
now in darkness what's more is we are
told by the authorities here that this
could last four weeks there may not be
any power for weeks they are calling it
a catastrophic transmission failure and
there are all of the knock-on effects
from that this isn't just about not
being able to charge your phone this is
about serious stuff we know of an icu
unit treating cobit patients that is now
without power they are struggling to
treat those patients because where do
you take them in the midst of a
hurricane you can't take them outside
these are people who need power we know
that in some areas the 911 emergency
lines are down nobody can call them
because they rely on power and of course
there are those people who are trapped
in their homes the temperature in the
last hour or so has really plummeted
here it's been hot and humid all day as
is often the case here uh in louisiana
now because of the rains it is pretty
cold so people will not even be able to
heat their homes and they have water
pouring in
the hurricane has now been downgraded
it's now category three so i mean you
could say that is good news if you could
call it that because it was category
four bordering on casualty five before
but those rains are still coming
so heavily i mean it has been raining
here non-stop for eight hours and it is
heavy rain this road here is like an
absolute river it is coming down in
sheets it is pouring into basements and
this is like as i say this is the french
quarter we are here on higher ground
there are those people who are in the
areas where the flood defenses are not
going to be helping who are going to be
having water pouring into their homes
one estimate said earlier today that we
were expecting 2.7 to 3 meters of water
in some areas now to put that into
context if you have 1.2 meters pour into
your home that is a very bad day your
home your ground floor will be ruined
2.7 to 3 meters means an entire floor is
completely submerged in those cases you
have to move to a higher ground you have
to move to an another floor if you are
not lucky enough to have another floor
if you live in a single-story home as
many people do here then the only option
is to go to the roof so we are expecting
people in the dark to be sitting on
their roofs because they have no other
option they have to save their lives by
climbing to higher ground and we've been
told by the authorities that you're
essentially on your own for at least 72
hours you should have enough food you
shouldn't have enough water you should
have enough backup power supply to look
after yourself for three days because as
i said this is across the entire city
now this could go on for quite some time
lenny thanks for that phil lavelle in
new orleans describing a very very
challenging situation for the people
living in louisiana and the surrounding
areas